[Music]
let's go to beth in
tucson arizona what's up beth
hi how's it going we are rocking on how
are you
good you know just trying to stay cool
oh yeah you're in arizona dude it's a
million degrees
you're trying to stay not dead
yes exactly so hot
ah so hot so what's up
okay so my question today is um how can
i best be a friend to my best friend who
has been battling cancer for three years
and continues to just get bad news after
bad news
what's bad news
um yeah i don't i'm trying not to go too
deep into um telling her story for her
but um
basically it's at the point now where
um it's alternate treatments and
okay so it's terminal yeah okay um well
and that's the thing that's hard about
being a friend too is it
you know i'm getting the information
from her as she's as she's willing to
share or and i know she's not wanting to
give up hope also and so um but it's
it's i know that it's we're at a hard
place for sure
cool so yeah so how can i help i'm so
sorry i mean i oh no
yeah i think it's just you know i've
we've been going through this um i've
been you know with her for the last few
years through covet and through
everything it's been such a weird time
to battle something like this and i
think i'm just finding myself
not sure how to be there for her or how
to i just want to be her friend i just
want to hang out and i just want to go
for a run with her but obviously that's
not where we are and so i just find
myself feeling a little helpless with
how i can
just be there for her as a friend in
this moment and kind of balance that
with
kind of you know the grief that i'm
dealing with um
and i think too over the last couple
months i've started to realize that i'm
grieving the friendship we had because
you know it's we
we've trained for triathlons together
we've done all this stuff together we've
raised our kids together
and it's just um
[Music]
yeah i'm just finding myself in a really
heavy place and i'm not sure
i'm trying to take care of myself and
make sure you know i just went on a
family vacation and trying to i keep
telling my husband i'm trying to hold
but the joy and the grief at the same
time and it's really difficult um but
i'm just at this point trying to figure
out how i can best be there for her as
she's navigating this
one she's lucky to have you
and
thanks for articulating that that way
you laid it out perfectly that that
balance is so hard how old are you
um we're both 35.
oh my gosh
yeah
what's the case
but um
well it's um colorectal cancer it's
either colon cancer yeah yeah breast
cancer yeah
yeah
so and it's good spread yeah
so what a mess
um
okay uh we'll loop through a couple of
things here all right
okay um
i'll start with you and then we'll work
out is that cool
yes
um
first this is gonna be hard to hear
joy is
often on the other side of grief
and you can make yourself insane trying
to force one and hold the other
okay
and so
this is a season of grief
for a hundred different reasons and it's
not selfish for you to grieve the loss
of your friendship
and it's not selfish to grieve the loss
of the plans you guys had to do a
triathlon when you're 40 and to be those
two wrinkly old 50 year old ladies
running in the neighborhood
like you had that picture in your head
and grieving that is the right thing to
do because it's not going to happen
because it's not going to happen
yeah that's i think that's the hard part
is that um
you know what she's dealing with is so
much heavier than this yeah i'm doing it
listen listen so hard okay listen
do not ever ever ever compare grief
your grief is yours
okay
okay that's a fool's errand and
everybody ends up worse off when we
compare grief
her looking at you going oh you think
you've got it bad i've got this
if she thinks that that doesn't help her
cancer no she's not that way of course
she's not right but i heard it a lot
during covid like oh well my husband
lost his job but at least not like
dennis my friend's husband who's on a
ventilator it's like well at least my
husband didn't die everybody's life was
hard right and so own where you are
right now
the one recurring challenge i hear from
people who are
get cancer
is that they say the hardest part of
getting cancer is often
making sure everyone else in their life
is okay
yeah and i'm very aware of that okay i'm
trying not to be that person to her um
and i'm trying to
the hardest part is just not
obviously i want to know how she's doing
and how but trying to find some normalcy
in our friendship okay listen there's
nothing
i know it's not it's just trying to i'm
trying to i it's like i just want to
give her a break
from this heaviness and i know i can't
but
yeah it's hard so as a person who's a
triathlete as a person who's going on
vacations and and writing down in your
planner that we will have joy right
which is probably who you are
um yes
there's nothing more terrifying
and nothing more um
um
there's no more feeling mortal
than watching someone who's very similar
to you
die
yes
and you can't control it
no and the control part is what makes
you nuts
yeah the letting go part and the being
really really sad and the grieving this
that's where there will like be light on
the other end of it but you gotta go
through the black hole first i wish
there was another one yeah
and i just think it's hard because i
mean i was at the we were at the park
with our kids the other day and it's
like it's
it's surreal right she's still here
she's still here she's still my friend
you would never look at her and even
know that she's sick um
it's very hard
all right so
i want you to loosen the control
and this is going to sound bonkers i
want you to lean into this discomfort
not away from it
okay lean into it and don't try to
control it okay what that looks like is
keep a record a journal of how you're
feeling
if you haven't started something keep it
and it'll be a great gift for her kids
one day
okay okay what you're gonna miss about
her
what you'll miss about you after she's
gone
that you're scared and alone and
terrified
and there's days you just wanna go hug
her and make this all better and you
can't write all that down because here's
what you're gonna do for her kids
you're gonna give them some words and
language to the hurt they feel after
mommy's gone
okay
okay
i also want you to
this is gonna sound bonkers but have you
sat down and asked her what do you need
um no
so okay um
you there's nothing worse
than dating a guy and men are the worst
about this about dating a guy and
he's like
i know what i'm getting her for
valentine's day a great make-out session
and yeah you know i mean like and he's
got all these ideas for how he's gonna
truly honor her and i always feel like
my buddies
have you have you asked your wife what
she wants because what she really might
want the greatest most romantic gift you
could give her is like you to go away
that could be awesome or to do the
dishes right so i tell you this when
somebody's hurting we often rush to fix
that person's hurt because we feel
uncomfortable and we're actually trying
to heal our own discomfort
right
i want you to go ask your friend
i love you we've done hard things
together and we're entering into mile
28.
and this is an uncharted run for both of
us
what do you need right now
yeah if you need me to stay away because
every time you see me you grieve what
you're not gonna have i'll stay away
if you need me to show up and just bring
tacos and ride this sucker down i'm
gonna let my nutrition go and we're
gonna eat beer drink beer and eat nachos
until this thing rides out
ask her what she needs
yeah and i think there's been seasons of
that i just think um
yeah i've just been in this
the last
few months of extra heaviness um
yeah don't try to fight the extra
heaviness because it's going to come
anyway
and quite honestly it's going to take
you with it
um can we do this um kelly
um is a cancer survivor and
um i would love to is it cool if i get
her insight on this yeah oh yes kelly
would you willing to say something of
course okay so
you may tell me john you're an idiot
that was terrible wisdom there you give
her um walk it through you get the
cancer diagnosis and then there's the
scary season yours obviously wasn't it
wasn't
quite the same thing um walk us through
your experience yeah hey beth so one
thing that john said about asking her
i actually raised my hands because it
was such a huge moment yes
my boss here
um
one of the greatest gifts he gave me was
he asked me how do you want us to treat
you
okay and i was and my answer was like
you did yesterday
and before all this because i didn't
want to be
babied and
everyone felt sorry for me and so by him
asking that
and i knew if i had said
well i'm i'm a little emotional so i
need you to be nicer to me they would
have done it he would have done it
but
the fact that he um let me be an adult
and didn't assume how i wanted to be
treated he allowed me to make that
decision
and then the biggest biggest thing is
when you're the person that that has
cancer or any issue other people's
feelings are exhausting
yes absolutely they really are they are
exhausting
and that was harder for me to deal with
in anything was everybody else's need to
tell me how i was going to be fine and
i'm so sorry and i'll pray for you i
know everybody meant well but by the
time i went home i was like crawling in
bed just because i was so tired
so yes i can feel that yeah finding
another way for that outlet your husband
another friend
um
yeah with her very very careful with
that and yeah i think i mean one thing
that's been
you know when we're with our kids it's
easy to just be moms and to be present
with each other and to laugh at our kids
and
have those late moments so i've tried
we've leaned into that but yeah i
definitely um
yeah i think it's
um you know i've given the hey let me
know how i can help or what i can do but
not as directive hey what how can i be
different i mean i'm asking you
beth you just said something that's hurt
you said something really important
don't hang on to
yeah when y'all are just being moms and
y'all just playing with your kids you
know just hanging out
that's one of the greatest gifts you can
give her yes but when you go home
that feeling you feel that's your grief
not hers
yes right and it's not her job to make
that grief go put her your grief on her
no definitely not yet right
she's getting
she's never going to forget she has
cancer
and if you don't talk about it or
you know all of a sudden you just
pretend like the old days trust me she's
not going to forget she's getting it
from her probably her husband her
doctors and a million other people that
mean well and everybody at her church
she needs somebody to treat her like a
friend
yeah just and i mean not everything's
not going to be normal but someone
that's going to laugh and you know make
fun of her if that's what you i mean my
friends and i are complete and totally
sarcastic
so you know when i had my mastectomy
there was jokes
lots lots of jokes
because that's what i needed i didn't
need somebody to pet me and go oh i'm so
very sorry i had plenty of that
i needed my friends to be my friends
still because i needed a sense of
normalcy
okay yeah so as much of that as you can
do and hey what can i do for you they're
never gonna no one's ever gonna say
well actually i really need someone to
go to the store just step in and say i'm
going to the store what do you want me
to get
yeah or i'm on my way over what do you
want from starbucks
yeah because people hate to ask
especially if they're like me they don't
want to ask for help
exactly so just stepping in and doing it
getting over there and just being her
friend
okay yeah and there's going to be some
weird moments thank you so much kelly
that's awesome um
my oldest greatest friends on the planet
is a paraplegic he's in a wheelchair
and
i've been stopped
we've been stopped in like
in grow in like restaurant parking lots
um because we're hassling each other so
much like somebody came and got into
into me and his little brother's face it
was like how dare you talk to him that
way and we were like whoa whoa whoa whoa
he's our friend he's our friend and
you it may be that she comes up to the
park with her friend and you're like
nice haircut
and she's like i know and somebody's
gonna look at you mean where they don't
get a vote this is your friendship yeah
right yeah or maybe she looks at you
goes i need you to treat me like a
princess great done no and i mean i
think i
it's really good to hear because i mean
we've always
throughout her treatments and through
and there's another friend involved who
doesn't live in town with us but um
you know we send each other funny memes
and all that stuff and i've kind of
stopped doing that because i'm like i
don't i know but i think maybe it's okay
we need to
keep the fun going and maybe be willing
specially
listen so yeah ask her
yeah because
my friend her name is kelly and when she
died of cancer
she had brain cancer very very very
young and
when it first when she her first couple
years of diagnosis
everybody knew it was terminal from day
one they shouldn't know how long
and
when she first got it she talked to
everybody she would go talk to the kids
in the cancer ward she would tell
hilarious jokes and we were relentless
back
um she's one of the most extraordinary
women i've ever met
but as they got further along and the
timeline was getting shorter and shorter
it was very clear
it's not funny and we're not going to
make jokes and what we want now is more
closeness and more hand-holding and more
hugs to be a little bit tighter and it
just shifted and everybody kept checking
in with what do you need what do you
need what do you need
and so um
let her steer that ship and even if you
have to say from this point forward i'm
gonna let you steer this like you tell
me what you need and i'm gonna keep
asking you once a week i'm gonna ask you
let me know how we can best love you
um
and you find support and love and care
for your grief maybe you and your other
friend
you all go get together you all go out
you all write each other letters
whatever that looks like
um
serve her kids whatever that looks like
but find outlets for that grief there
too
and i'll reiterate what i said earlier
she is really lucky to have you as her
friend
man
thank you for loving hurting people beth
you're awesome